en principe quand on est réceptionner il
ne repousse plus en principe va
peut-être disparaître
une équipe de chercheurs suisses a fait
un très grand pas un pas d'un demi
millimètre ils ont fait repousser anr
d'un demi-millimètre cela peut paraître
dérisoire mais cela peut avoir des
conséquences importantes pour ceux qui
souffrent ou qui souffriront de lésions
importantes de la moelle épinière
jean daniel flaysakier moelle épinière
véritable circuit de transmission des
ordres venus du cerveau à destination
notamment de nos quatre membres quand
sept mois allaient sectionner ce sont
des centaines de nerfs qui sont arrachés
qui ne vont pas repousser tout cela
parce qu'au pied de la lésion une série
de réactions chimiques et toxiques va
empêcher le nerf de rejoindre l'autre
partie arrachée à travers le monde comme
ici à l'hôpital de la pitié salpêtrière
à paris
les spécialistes cherchent à pallier cet
inconvénient est aujourd'hui une équipe
suisse vient de réussir sur l'animal ce
qui peut être considéré comme un progrès
très importants ces chercheurs ont
administré deux substances aux animaux
la première substance sert à lutter
contre les effets nocifs qui se passe au
pied de la lésion
la seconde substance aide le nerf a
repoussé
résultat ils ont obtenu une croissance
de 0,5 mm cela peut paraître négligeable
mais c'est en fait presque un pas de
géant qui ouvre de nombreuses
perspectives et bien sûr on pense tout
de suite à la recherche sur l'être
humain fois encore certainement pas mal
de temps mais faut-il de compter en
années ou en dizaines d'années c'est
encore difficile de le savoir
nous espérons que ça sera une question
d'années mais il ya encore beaucoup
beaucoup de travail pour les chercheurs
en tout cas aujourd'hui les chercheurs
sont confortées ils savent qu'ils sont
sur la bonne voie